King F7 player and he comes back with
the Rook to F5 and now you can just wait
with your Rook on the E Line oh there's
a trade and this is a draw for because
now Black's King is in the right Square
uh we'll see a stalemate being played
out in this one
or maybe not or we might even see a king
versus King and game all the way to the
the bare bones of the position and uh
uh everyone should know this ending if
you don't know this ending
um you you have to well if you don't
know this position that's okay but you
know we've got extra pawn and they have
agreed a draw there
um very impressed with prague's play
Tanya in that game because he was under
some serious pressure throughout he kept
finding very resourceful ways to uh uh
just to defend right he was defending
for most of the game and he did it
brently
um under pressure